[de la musique] étrangère
de l'exposition est de
parler de l'
échec et de le déstigmatiser et, dans une
certaine mesure, de l'accepter et
de comprendre qu'il s'agit d'un
élément très important si nous voulons
innover et résoudre les grands problèmes du
monde que nous allons avoir.  prendre des
risques et essayer différentes choses
[Musique]
merci
les produits dont nous disons que leurs
échecs sont
subjectifs
discutables mais c'est à propos de cette
conversation que nous nous amusons en quelque sorte,
nous voulons en éliminer la stigmatisation,
donc je  je pense que le facteur amusant
le rend beaucoup plus
attrayant pour les gens
d'aujourd'hui avec les médias sociaux.
Je crois qu'il est plus difficile d'échouer. Je
pense que les gens ont l'impression que
leurs échecs sont en quelque sorte amplifiés sur les
médias sociaux et cela vous suit en quelque sorte
et cela semble peut-être plus grand qu'il ne l'est
en réalité.  est
[Musique]